consideremos ahora las unidades
típicamente usadas en el sistema métrico
para medir el peso de un objeto y estoy
poniendo la palabra peso entre comillas
porque en realidad técnicamente hablando
las unidades que vamos a revisar aquí
son unidades para medir la masa de los
objetos pues como veremos posteriormente
nuestros vídeos científicos
peso y masa no son lo mismo están
íntimamente relacionadas masa es la
cantidad de sustancia de un objeto esta
unidad nos da una medida de qué tan
difícil es cambiar la velocidad o mover
un objeto mientras que peso es cuál es
la fuerza con la cual la gravedad está
jalando ese objeto de manera cotidiana
si te encuentras en un mismo lugar en el
planeta si algo tiene más masa va a
tener más peso y si algo tiene más peso
va a tener más masa es por eso que estos
términos se usan de manera
intercambiable posteriormente veremos
cuál es la diferencia técnica entre
estos términos para fines de este vídeo
dado que estamos familiarizándonos con
las unidades del sistema métrico puede
usar peso y masa como sinónimos cómo se
usa cotidianamente sin tomar en cuenta
el sentido establecido para estos
términos por la ciencia física
así es que en el sistema métrico para
referirnos al peso de objetos ligeros
usualmente se usa el gramo y para tener
idea de lo que es un gramo de peso
tenemos por ejemplo el clip el clip que
usamos para poner papeles juntos mide
aproximadamente un gramo también un
chicle no todo el paquete tan solo una
barrita una barrita de goma de mascar va
a pesar aproximadamente un gramo un
billete de un dólar un billete de un
dólar también pesa aproximadamente un
gramo como puedes ver estos son objetos
que realmente no pesan mucho a una
escala mayor a la escala del ser humano
por ejemplo podemos multiplicar el gramo
por 1000 y así tendríamos el kilo gramo
kilogramo en el sistema métrico el
prefijo kilo significa multiplicar por
mil
así es que kilogramos significa 1000
gramos para tener una idea de cuánto
peso representa un kilogramo en el
sistema métrico el peso de las personas
se mide en kilogramos yo por ejemplo
peso aproximadamente
30 kilogramos mide unos 68 soy de
complexión regular y mi peso es
aproximadamente de 70 kilogramos y para
tener una idea de lo que pesa un
kilogramo imaginemos un litro de un
líquido más específicamente un litro de
agua para obtener un litro podemos
construir un cubo un cubo que tiene 10
centímetros de profundidad 10
centímetros de ancho y 10 centímetros de
alto y este lo llenamos de agua y eso
ese litro de agua pesa un kilogramo pero
claro la gente no va paseando por ahí
con cubos de un litro de agua así es que
puedes imaginar que cuando vas al
supermercado y compras
una botella digamos de refresco de 2
litros de refresco o botellas de 2
litros de agua de hecho para ser más
precisos tiene que ser una botella de
dos litros de agua el refresco tiene
otras sustancias así es que dos litros
de refresco no pesan precisamente dos
kilogramos pero una botella que contiene
dos litros de agua es así es
pesar exactamente dos kilogramos estamos
hablando del peso preciso del agua
contenida no estamos tomando en cuenta
el peso del envase así es que los dos
litros de agua contenidos en ese envase
pesan exactamente dos kilogramos
entonces para medir el peso de objetos
en una escala humana o de líquidos o
algo que se encuentra a ese nivel el que
manejamos los humanos vamos a usar el
kilogramo para objetos que son
extremadamente ligeros usaremos el gramo
ahora para medir el peso de objetos a
una escala menor objetos que son
realmente ligeros como las dosis que se
usan en los medicamentos entonces vamos
a usar el miligramo el mili gramos pero
imagínate el miligramo es una milésima
de un gramo el peso de una milésima
parte de un billete de un dólar o el
peso de una milésima parte de un clip
esto es realmente mucho muy mucho muy
muy muy pequeño está unidad de peso
aparece solo raramente en la vida
cotidiana